Mike worked at McDonald's
for eight years,
and I think we all know
why he doesn't
work there anymore--
they took away
all the incentives.
I mean, they tore down
all the playgrounds.
Really lucky that both your
opponents look like pedophiles.
Uh...
You know, people are asking me
tonight if I'm gonna
put Sarah in her place.
She's a 38-year-old woman
in comedy-- there isn't one.
(gunshot sound effect plays)
That's amazing.
That's funny. Uh...
Mike hates sports, obviously.
Uh...
For someone
who doesn't like sports,
you sure do look
a lot like a 49er.
Oh, it's Canada.
(bleep) me.
Goddamn it.
I'm sure someone will after.
Uh...
Sarah's vagina is like a bar:
it's dank, full of drunk dicks,
and children are immediately
forced to leave.
AUDIENCE:
Oh!
(applause)